on va faire 40 ans dans quelques jours
john lennon qui a été assassiné le 8
décembre 1980
et c'est fait vous avez plongé dans les
archives de radio-canada pour commencer
on sourit à nouveau du poète rsa
nniversaire giornale avait 40 ans
lorsqu'il a été assassiné il ya près de
40 ans de 8 décembre 1980 john lennon et
yoko ono au revenait à la maison après
une séance d'enregistrement ils étaient
devant leur immeuble de center parcs
lorsqu'un homme surgit tiré en direction
du chanteur les mines a été transporté
d'urgence à l'hôpital sur la banquette
arrière d'une voiture de police
il avait perdu beaucoup de sa et selon
les médecins il n'avait aucune chance de
survivre
voici comment on en parlait sur nos
ondes au lendemain de sa mort le 9
décembre 1980 avec le journaliste
présentateur gérard mary gouard la
disparition à 40 ans de cet auteur
compositeur marque la fin d'une époque
avec paul mccartney john lennon fuite en
effet à l'origine de la formation des
beats au genre 1958 à liverpool depuis
la rupture du groupe dans soixante dix
on n'a pas cessé d'espérer une réunion
des quatre britanniques qui chacun de
leur côté ont continué leur carrière
messi a frappé le plus peut-être dans la
mort violente de lénine c'est le
contraste avec sa vie lui qui des quatre
a toujours été celui qui a le plus prôné
la paix et la non violence
d'ailleurs on se rappellera son séjour à
montréal en 69 alors que d'une chambre
d'hôtel en compagnie de sa femme yoko
ono ils avaient organisé un sit in pour
la paix je suis contre la violence point
final
la violence engendre que la violence qui
se passe aux etats unis le prouve bien
tout ce qui en sort ce sont les coups
sur la tête et des manchettes sur la
violence et la p1 c'est vrai que c'est
le mot qui résume le mieux la vie et ce
bed-in de 1969 dans une chambre de
l'hôtel reine elizabeth à montréal a
vraiment marqué nos esprits
au lendemain de sa mort sur nos ondes on
a recueilli plusieurs témoignages pour
parler de jonen notamment celui de
georges hébert germain journaliste
écrivain qui lui-même est décédé il ya
cinq ans il parlait des valeurs de john
madden
c'est peut-être un pur et vert
d'ailleurs qu'un l'ena ne fait ses
premiers disques après la dissolution
des beatles dans imaging disait bon me
dit que je suis un rêveur mais il faut
rêver il faut se forcer continuer à
rêver pour finalement changer la réalité
c'est au bout du rêve si on ne rêve pas
la réalité ne changera pas et tout toute
cette période le 68 les fleurs les
cheveux longs etc
c'était très c'est très rêveur s'ils ont
vu et quarante ans plus tard est-ce que
l'assassin de john lennon est toujours
en prison
il est toujours en prison mark chapman
qui a été condamné à la prison à vie
mais puisqu'il avait plaidé coupable il
pouvait cependant obtenir une libération
conditionnelle après vingt ans de prison
ce qu'ils demandent régulièrement depuis
l'an 2000 et ce qu'il n'a jamais obtenu
c'est un tragique anniversaire que celui
de la mort de john lennon dont ses
admirateurs et admiratrices se
souviennent chaque année un an après sa
mort le 8 décembre 1941 il rassemblement
important devant l'immeuble dakota à new
york la résidence de yoko ono
voici comment on en parlait sur nos
envies des centaines de personnes ont
entrepris une vigile en face du dakota
l'immeuble où demeure encore la compagne
de john lennon yoko ono silencieux sous
la pluie il rendait un dernier hommage à
celui qui chantait débit aux chances des
dizaines de gerbes de fleurs ont été
envoyés à yoko qui a émis un communiqué
remerciant tous ceux qui ont exprimé
leur amitié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ça c'était bien sûr en 1981
et puis plus on s'approche du temps des
fêtes j'ai envie de vous faire entendre
quelques secondes une magnifique chanson
de 1971 du groupe de yoko ono et john
madden happy christmas ou à raison avec
grand plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]